today we're talking about updates to
infrastructure memory store
looker and contextual tutorials i'm ryan
and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news in the span of just three months
google cloud teams delivered a ton of
new and innovative capabilities for
compute
networking storage serverless and
containers
from transfer appliance to tau vms to
scaling
check out the summary to see what you
may have missed maintenance is critical
but related down times can be costly
we're excited to announce that cloud
memory store now enables you to have
more control over when your cloud memory
store for redis instances undergo
routine maintenance
this control comes in the form of
rescheduling and advanced notification
capabilities
which will be familiar controls for
cloud sql users
head to the blog to learn more the
extension framework is a fully hosted
development platform that enables
developers to build any data-powered
application
workflow or tool right in looker by
eliminating the need to spin up and host
infrastructure
the extension framework lets developers
focus on building great experiences for
their users
did you know that there's a way to learn
how to use google cloud products built
right into the google cloud console
in console tutorials can walk you
through completing actions without
having to open another window for
documentation
features like spotlights buttons and
code snippets make getting your project
up and running easier than ever
they'll pop up automatically but to
check out our list of existing firestore
tutorials
head to the linked blog if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud